hello there guys and welcome to another
video now this is a really exciting
video regarding the book of boba fett we
have a leaked description regarding a
very cool sound and scene which you guys
want to stick around for and also a
rumor of a potential character that
could show up in the series so before i
get into the video i do want to put a
disclaimer that they will be spoilers
but they're out of the way let's just
get straight into the video so first off
i'll talk about the leaked scene so a
reliable source has described the scene
from the book of obed in the scene boba
fett will be encountering and quite
possibly taming slash controlling a
rancor the source is not completely
positive when riva fett is fighting the
beast or controlling it buffett is seen
standing on top of the rancor's neck and
looks like he's riding or controlling it
as it tears for a city street or what is
likely tattooing now there was actually
an artist which created a rendering on
all these details that were told so i'll
describe the picture for you guys so the
rancor is wearing a huge chest plate
armor and wrist guards the rancor is
much lighter in comparison to the one in
our return to jedi that luke kills and
it's more of a
like a sandy color so i'm actually
wondering is this rancor moochie the one
from the bad batch that would actually
be a really cool connection to see
because i was actually disappointed to
find out that um the rancor in return
for jedi wasn't moochie wasn't the one
from the bad batch and i know other fans
were disappointed about that also so if
this rancor turns out to be either one
for the bad batch i feel like that would
satisfy a lot of people including me so
that is something i hope to see and i
gotta say this scene is sound pretty
sick and you know we haven't really seen
like a rancor with armor before so you
know there'll be something different and
we haven't seen a rancor in action and
live action yet so you know seeing one
just you know tear through a city and
just wreak havoc will be a really cool
scene to see so you know i hope this is
true and you know will just make boba
fett more of a badass than he is
currently anyway over to the other part
of the video there is a rumor of a
potential character from the clone wars
that may be in the book of pope fit and
this character is apparently cad bane
now i'm not sure this would be like a
flashback or something because cad bane
is presumably dead already so i'm not
sure how they'll fit that in the show if
this is true or maybe you survive um but
you know what i think they'll be really
sick if we can see campaign in live
action he's become a fan favorite from
the clone wars and you know he returned
for the bad batch and the episodes with
him were great so i hope we can see him
in some form in the book of boba fett
you know just to get our live-action
debut anyway that's pretty much about it
for this video so tell me in the comment
section below what you think of this
would you like to see cad bane return
what do you think of this leaked scene
of boba fett taming or controlling a
rancor and tearing through a city on
tatooine just let me know in the comment
section below with that out of the way
please like and subscribe and i'll catch
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching guys
foreign